and so in the great heritage ordinary
fighting 2008 featuring Hank John the
Katherine and a minivan good morning
Hank it's Monday and I am driving a
minivan through the great state of
Missouri I'm in fact driving the exact
same minivan that Q's mom owns in Paper
Towns which is one of the reasons that
we picked it for the great American tour
to nerdfighting 2008 by the way when I
say good morning Hank I mean it good
morning Hank good morning John
thanks for filming my vlog for me today
I'm gonna edit it too so you sound like
an idiot
haha we're driving right now on our way
to a nerdfighter gathering in st. Louis
yesterday we were in both Plano Texas
and Oklahoma City Oklahoma
both those gatherings were awesome and
we announced the release of Hanks first
studio album so joke's cure the music is
too high
but it's too hard
I wanna boogie Oh Helen huh
Helen Hana you make my heart do
acrobatics stunts we listen to the whole
thing yesterday it's just amazing it's
only for sale on the Tour de
nerdfighting sorry if you're not coming
to a nerdfighter gathering but if you
are you've got to pick up the CD that
costs $15 and no we cannot take credit
cards also in Plano Texas we met Sean
Achmed the guy from Bangladesh who has
been working with Save the Children to
make the world suck less through our
money and we'll be collecting money for
Save the Children Bangladesh throughout
the entire tour you guys only hear
something crazy
no a guy comes up to me at the
nerdfighter gathering in Oklahoma City
and he says I have a copy of booking for
Alaska that is unlike any other copy of
Looking for Alaska in the world and I
was like oh yeah sure whatever he held
it out it was packed and he said this
copy of Looking for Alaska was half
eaten by a Hawaiian Mongoose and ash
like okay full points I totally believe
in because he looked like the kind of
guy who did professionally wrestled
Hawaiian mongooses it's been a lot of
chicken in the car with Katherine Hank
although that's been a lot of fun
Katherine and Hank are excellent company
in a minivan we missed the Yeti but we
do keep her right here
hello Yeti
you're coming home to you tomorrow for
the election day spectacular in
Greenwood Indiana after that we will be
in Louisville Kentucky then we'll be in
Knoxville Tennessee and then we'll be in
Gadsden Alabama the spiralling shape
that's the best part of being on a road
trip would be dying us to sing then he
drives over the rumble strips rumble
strips rumble strips are my main party
driving I love the sound of a rumble
strip makes my but my brain I know
that's good you got to get the deep vein
thrombosis out I love you Missouri dang
it
Kathryn and I have this friendly
competition about who is going to spot
cows first and she's up like 888 million
to one I think we should like quit
riding an eco geek and just do this
full-time
buy a minivan travel around the country
meet nerdfighters spew carbon dang it
how did we're all cows here they're like
three miles away nerdfighters make me
believe in America again why don't you
close out the fall cank Hank I'll see
you tomorrow
PS there's an Tour de nerdfighting
Twitter stream which will be constantly
broadcasting updates from the road I
have this extraordinarily exciting
device here which lets me be on the
internet even when I'm in a minivan damn
it cows I'm so bad at cows I'm John I'll
be broadcasting all the nerdfighter
gatherings on blogtv there's a link at
the sidebar for both the Twitter and the
blog TV no horses you thought child I
thought I had it but it was horses